[MUSIQUE] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle
[MUSIQUE] C'est..... L'ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE
NARRATEUR - Haha, je le sens d'ici
Tu te demandes sûrement ce que tu es en train d'écouter ?
Cher auditeur. Tu vas découvrir une aventure débordante de rebondissements
Et de sauts dans le temps
De personnages énergiques et charismatiques.
Mais notre aventure commence de nos jours
avec un jeune homme sans énergie ni charisme.
Nous sommes dans la chambre de Thomas.
MÈRE - Allez Thomas ! Ça va aller !
THOMAS - Non maman, j'peux pas surmonter ça !
THOMAS  - Je suis amoureux d'elle...
MÈRE - T'en fais trop ! Elle était pas si incroyable. Tu mérites mieux !
THOMAS - Tu l'as jamais vu maman...
MÈRE - Oui bah, montre-moi une photo!
MÈRE - Wow ! Le canon ! C'est une mannequin, ou un truc comme ça non?
MÈRE - C'est quoi son prénom?
THOMAS - Elle s'appelle Iris et elle me manque tellement...
MÈRE - Ne t'inquiètes pas, elle va revenir.
MÈRE - Regarde son nouveau copain à côté d'elle, il est trop moche !
THOMAS - C'est moi maman...
MÈRE - Ah, oui c'est vrai...
MÈRE - Euh... Elle a rompu comment?
THOMAS - Elle a disparu du jour au lendemain, sans donner de nouvelles...
THOMAS - ...pas un message... pas une lettre !
MÈRE - Elle t'as fait une "papa" quoi...
MÈRE - Mais attends... T'es pas sûr qu'elle a rompu !
THOMAS - Comment ça ?
MÈRE - Si ça se trouve, elle a disparu ! Si ça se trouve elle est juste morte!
THOMAS - Quoi ?
THOMAS - Iris est... morte ?! *Pleurs*
MÈRE - Roooh, ça va!
MÈRE - Elle est vivante, c'est une catastrophe, elle est morte c'est une catastrophe!
MÈRE - Bon écoute Thomas, il est tant de passer à autre chose...
MÈRE - Ça fait quoi... Une semaine?
THOMAS - Un mois...
MÈRE - UN MOIS ?!
MÈRE - Et t'es encore en train de chialer?
MÈRE - Il faut aller de l'avant ! Tu es mon fils et je n'aime pas te voir comme ça...
MÈRE - Tu sais ce qui pourrais te requinquer ? Voler de tes propre ailes !
MÈRE - T'as pensé à avoir ton propre chez-toi?
THOMAS - Tu me vires maman?
MÈRE - Mais non ! Je dis ça pour toi !
MÈRE - Ça ne te ferait pas plaisir d'avoir ton propre chez-toi?
MÈRE - Et puis moi... j'aurais mon propre chez-moi...
THOMAS - Mais ça ne change rien.
MÈRE - Mais si !
MÈRE - Tu pourrais voir tes copains et jouer à tes jeux et moi...
MÈRE -  je pourrais voir mes copains et jouer à "mes" jeux...
THOMAS - Mais maman, j'ai pas de copain.
MÈRE - Et bien moi j'en ai plein.
MÈRE - Si ça se trouve, il existe une fille qui ne fait pas attention au physique
MÈRE - qui attend que de rencontrer un garçon gentil comme toi
MÈRE - et qui cherche un colocataire !
MÈRE - J'ai déjà sélectionné quelques annonces...
*ça tape à la porte*
MÈRE - OUI BON ÇA VA J'ARRIVE !!!
THOMAS - Oh... Iris... T’étais la femme de ma vie... *Pleure*
MÈRE - Thomas, t'as un p'tit copain qui est venu te rendre visite !
THOMAS - Quoi !?
ROBOT - Bonjour cher humain.
THOMAS - Mais maman... c'est un ROBOT !
MÈRE - Comment tu parles te tes petits copains, c'est pas gentil !
MÈRE - Excuse-le, il est chamboulé, une fille mieux que lui l'a quitté...
ROBOT - Je comprends.
THOMAS - Mais maman c'est pas du tout un ami à moi ! C'est... c'est un robot, c'est une machine !
ROBOT - Pas du tout, je suis un humain.
MÈRE - Ah ! tu vois !
THOMAS - Mais non ! Il est en métal, il porte même pas d'habits !
ROBOT - Tu n'as aucune preuve.
THOMAS- Bien sûr que j'ai des preuves! T'es tout en métal ! Écoutes le bruit que tu fais !
*BONK*
THOMAS - Aie... Ma main...
ROBOT - On fait exactement le même bruit.
*PIF PAF*
THOMAS - Aaaah !
ROBOT - Effectivement on ne fait pas le même bruit. Je suis démasqué.
ROBOT - J'avoue, je suis un robot.
THOMAS - Oh bah merci ! Putain, c'est super douloureux...
THOMAS - Tu vois maman c'est un robot !
MÈRE - Bon écoutez, moi j' y connais rien avec vos "snapchat", vos "face de bouc" !
MÈRE - Faites pas de bêtises les garçons !
ROBOT - Promis ! Merci Madame
THOMAS - Mais ne parles pas à ma mère comme si tu étais mon pote !
THOMAS - Oh putain je parle à une machine...
ROBOT - Bon ! Où est Iris ?
THOMAS - QUOI !? Tu... tu connais Iris ?
ROBOT - Elle est ici ?
THOMAS - Non, ça fait des mois qu'elle donne plus de nouvelles !
THOMAS - Tu l'as connais d'où ? Elle t'as parlé de moi récemment ?
ROBOT - Hm... Je vois...
ROBOT - Elle a dû changer de temporalité. Ça ne m'arrange pas.
THOMAS - Quoi ?
*Bruits de machine hautement sophistiquée*
ROBOT - J'ai capté son empreinte à une autre époque. Elle doit se trouver là-bas.
THOMAS - Quoi... ?
ROBOT - Désolé du dérangement. Bonne continuation dans tout vos formidables projets.
ROBOT - Retemporalisation dans 5... 4... 3...
THOMAS - Attends ! Tu sais où est Iris ?!
THOMAS - Ne pars pas ! Hé, tu m'écoutes ?!
*bruit de voyage dans le temps avec une petite musique qui met dans l'ambiance*
THOMAS - Wow !
THOMAS - Qu'est-qu'il vient de se passer ? On est où là ?
ROBOT - À la vue des arbres au loin, de l'étendue d'herbe et de la vue dégagée
ROBOT - je dirais qu'on est dans "une clairière".
THOMAS - Je vois bien qu'on est dans une clairière mais, on était dans ma chambre il y a quelques secondes !
ROBOT - Oui on y est plus ça c'est sûr.
ROBOT - On est au "Pays de Galles" en "1314"
ROBOT - pas très loin du "Château de Beaumaris".
THOMAS - Tu t'fous de ma gueule ? On est en 1300... combien ?!
THOMAS - Comment tu veux que j'crois ça ?
ROBOT - Je ne sais pas, je suis un robot, tu t'es téléporté, ça devrait suffire.
THOMAS - Ouais c'est vrai, que dit comme ça...
ROBOT - De toute façon tu n'aurais pas du t'approcher de moi pendant le voyage temporel
ROBOT - Je vais te renvoyer dans ton époque.
*bruit de retemporalisation*
THOMAS - Nan ! Nan surtout pas !
*arrêt de la retemporalisation*
THOMAS - Tu m'as dit que tu savais où était Iris ?
THOMAS - Je t'accompagne !
ROBOT - Désolé mais tu ne me sers à rien. Hmm... sauf si tu sais te battre à l'épée.
THOMAS - Euh... non.
ROBOT - Hmm... Pas grave, tu pourras toujours servir de leurre dans une situation délicate.
THOMAS - Ouais ! Ça je sais faire le... leurre !
THOMAS - Bon , où est Iris ?
ROBOT - D'après ses traces temporelles, elle serait dans ce château là-bas.
*musique ellipse*
Thomas : Et tu viens d'où exactement ?
Robot : Du futur
Thomas : Oh j'en était sur !
Et t'as un nom du genre C3XZ ou ...
Robot : Je suis un robot donc j'ai un nom avec des chiffres et des lettres ?
Thomas : Bah ouais comme euh ... R2D2
Robot : Non, je ne suis pas un vulgaire robot
Je suis très respecté dans mon époque et je m'appelle : *voix différente* Elliot
Thomas : Aah ...Elliot27 ?
Elliot : Juste *voix différente* Elliot.
C'est très raciste envers les robots ! C'est *voix différente* robophobe.
Ça te plairait que je t'appelle Thomas54 ?
Thomas : Eh c'était le nom de mon Skyblog !
Eh mais c'est quoi le trou que t'as dans le ventre là ?
Elliot : Rien n'y touche pas !
Thomas : Si ! Si avec le bouton là !
*interrupteur* *bip bip bip bip*
Thomas : Ahhh !!!! Mais ça brûle !!!
*snif *Et mais... mais c'est du café ! Elliot tu fais du café ! Mais...mais t'es une machine à café !
Elliot : Pas du tout !! *voix différente* Souhaitez vous du sucre ?
Thomas : Euh... deux.
*bip bip*
Elliot : Bon ok tu m'as grillé... Mais je sais faire plein d'autre truc !
Et aussi c'est vrai un... *voix différente* café d'expression arabica avec la machine KB-28, un café savoureux et corsé.
D'accord *bruit de trompette* Ah on y c'est c'est bon !
Wouah ! Ils baissent le pont-levis c'est sympa !
*bruit de pont-levis*
*Trompette*
Thomas : Et on est accueilli par une dizaine d'homme regarde Elliot !
*apeuré* Qui ont des regards menaçants... Oh putain merde Elliot !
Ils vont nous fusiller !
Elliot : Pas d'inquiétude, le fusil sera inventé dans plus de cent ans.
*Musique inquiétante*
Thomas : Ohhh.... tu me rassures Elliot...
Elliot : Ils vont plutôt nous transpercé avec des flèches ou des lances.
Un soldat : Ne faites pas un pas de plus ! Vils intrus ! Ou on vous transperce avec nos flèches et nos lances !
Les soldats : Ouais !!!!
Elliot : Tu vois.
Thomas : Euh...Elliot... Rassure moi, si ça se passe mal tu peux remonter le temps et tout va bien ? C'est ça ?
Elliot : Si une lance te transperce la tête, ça sert à rien de remonter le temps tu es juste mort.
Par contre je peux t'enterrer dans l'époque de ton choix.
Thomas : Non.. ça... ça ira...
Elliot : Laisse moi faire
Oyez valeureux soldats !
Un soldat : Qu'est ce que vous voulez ?
Elliot : Nous venons en paix !
Un soldat : Pourquoi qu'on devrait vous croire ?
Mes compagnons ! Regarder l'accoutrement de ces gueux !!
Ils viennent pas d'chez nous !!
Les soldats : Tuons les ! Tuons les !
Elliot : Chers gens, ne faites pas attention à nos accoutrements.
On vient offrir nos services à votre roi.
Je suis un chevalier en armure. Écoutez!
*Bonk*
Et mon compagnon de route aux vêtements originaux est un troubadour !
Un soldat : Prouvez-le !                                                        Les soldats : Ouais !!
Thomas : Ouais...
Elliot? C'est quoi un troubadour?
Elliot : Chante quelque chose
Un soldat : Vous voyez. C'est un mensonge!
TUONS-LES!
Les soldats : TUONS-LES! TUONS-LES!
Elliot : Allez Thomas
Thomas  : Je connais rien comme chanson moi..
Elliot : Mort de Thomas car il ne veut pas chanter dans 5, 4, 3, 2, 1
Thomas : Euhhhh... Ok, ok! Euh..
🎶 Libérée, délivrée. Je ne mentirai plus jamais! 🎶
🎶 Libérée, délivrée! Je connais plus après.. 🎶
*Une mouche passe*
*Applaudissement*
Un soldat : J'adore cette chanson. Elle est simple et entrainante.
Thomas : Oh YES.
Un soldat : On cherche d'ailleurs un hymne pour notre nation. Elle me semble parfaite.
Entrez mes amis!
Elliot : Nous acceptons votre hospitalité mon bon ami.
Thomas : Oui! Mes chers gens, l'amabilité que vous portez...
Elliot : Tais-toi! Tu vas nous faire démasquer.
Thomas : Ouais, t'as raison Elliot. J'ai voulu faire comme toi c'était nul..
Un soldat: Allez offrir vos services à la reine
Elle se situe au fond du château.
[MUSIQUE]
Thomas : Yes, pas de lance dans le crâne. Elliot, on a trop géré.
Bon, on va trouver Iris.
Voilà! Euh.. On a qu'à se disperser. On cherche discrètement chaque recoin du château.
Si l'un de nous trouve Iris, et bah il fait un cri de pigeon qu'on reconnaîtra..
Elliot : On va demander à la reine si elle a vu Iris.
Thomas : Ouais. Ouais, on va faire  ce que tu dis finalement, Elliot.
Attend. T'es sûr qu'elle est bien ici Iris?
Elliot : J'ai capté des traces d'elle dans cet endroit et dans cette temporalité.
Thomas : Ok, très bien. Mais? Pourquoi tu la cherches d'ailleurs?
*Trompettes*
Thomas : Whaaa! Il sort d'où lui? Il m'a fait peur le con.
*Claquement de porte*
Un homme : Oyez ma reine! Voici les visiteurs.
La Reine : Chers visiteurs!...
KB-28? C'est toi, KB-28?
Elliot : La machine KB-28 pour un café d'exception!
Bonjour Iris!
Thomas : IRIS?!
Iris : THOMAS?! Mais qu'est-ce que tu fous là?
Thomas : Mais non, toi... Toi, qu'est-ce que tu fous là?!
[MUSIQUE]
Mais c'est vrai ça! Que fout l'ex-copine de Thomas sur un trône au Moyen-Âge?
Moi, je sais... Je sais tout.
Je sais même la fin.
Mais pour toi, il va falloir attendre le prochain épisode.
[MUSIQUE] L'épopée temporelle ne fait que commencer.
[MUSIQUE] Et nos personnages s'apprêtent à traverser bien des épreuves.
[MUSIQUE]
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouter le premier épisode de l'Épopée temporelle.
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne rien louper de la suite, à mettre un petit pouce en l'air.
Et moi, je vous dis à la semaine prochaine. Il va se passer pleins de choses.